يقف بصير في هذا الصف الطويل للحصول على
جواز السفر يقول انه تم ترشيحه للحصول على
الجواز قبل سته اشهر لكنه اليوم سيحصل
عليه املا في الحصول على فرصه عمل في
الخارج
اريد ان احصل على جواز السفر لاجل العمل
لا توجد هنا فرص العمل اريد ان اغادر
البلد لاعمل في الخارج
حميد الله هو الثاني الذي ينتظر في هذا
الصف المكتظ لاستلام الجواز يقول انه
محظوظ اذ هو يقف هنا في اول يوم من بدء
عمليه التوزيع ليحصل على جواز السفر وارسل
للحصول على جواز السفر العام الماضي وبعد
عام اخبرتني المديريه العامه لاصدار
الجوازات انها تقدم لي اليوم جوازا وساحصل
عليه اليوم ان شاء الله فان عمليه التوزيع
تستمر
المديريه العامه لاصدار الجوازات تؤكد ان
عمليه التوزيع لن تتوقف وانها قامت بحل
جميع المشاكل الفنيه التي كانت تعرقل
عمليه التوزيع بخلقه طلبات المواطنين
للحصول على جواز السفر كثيره ونحن نسعى ان
نستوعبها جميعا وسنبذل قصار جهدنا
وامكانياتنا وقد حددنا ان نوزع عشره الاف
جواز بشكل يومي في عموم البلاد
تبدا المديريه العامه باصدار الجوازات
للمواطنين الافغان في وقت لا يعترف العالم
بحكومه طالبان والجوازات التي تصدرها
المديريه هي باسم النظام السابق دوله
جمهوريه افغانستان الاسلاميه
جواز السفر حق دستوري لكل مواطن بات
الحصول عليه يشكل ازمه للمواطن الافغاني
في وقت تقدم طلبات كثيره للحصول عليه لكن
عائق الحصول على جواز السفر لا يزال قائما
عبد الانادر العربيه كابول